il paraît très qu'on connaît mieux notre
système solaire que les fonds marins
démonstration comment s'appelle le
liquide présent au fond de l'océan je
sais pas comment s'appelle l'étoile au
centre du système solaire je sais
[Musique]
pour savoir si les vrais qu'on connaît
moins bien les fonds marins nous avons
demandé son expertise d'experts à une
experte des sols et de la géologie de la
terre elle aime lécher des cailloux et
elle a une sœur jumelle morte qui
reporter de guerre je vous présente
Valentine de science de comptoir bonjour
Alors Valentine dites-nous tout
est-ce que c'est vrai qu'on connaît
mieux le système solaire que le fond des
océans c'est vrai mais il paraît que
c'est une zone très difficile à
atteindre c'est exact et d'ailleurs on
sait encore très peu de choses sur cet
endroit y compris la faune et la flore
qui vivent tout à fait et bien merci
Valentine pour cette partie de ni oui ni
non et pour cette expertise sans
précédent nous reviendrons peut-être
vous demander votre expertitude dans
jamais si on connaît pas très bien du
tout les fonds marins c'est parce que
c'est très compliqué d'y aller
visiblement c'est plus simple d'envoyer
des gens sur la lune lol jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en 2023 en tout 12 hommes au
marché sur la lune mais seulement 6
hommes et une femme ont plongé tout au
fond de la fausse des Mariannes
l'endroit le plus profond des océans un
endroit plein de mystères et de pénombre
où la vie semble comme suspendu à un fil
au fond de la fosse des Mariannes à
10984 mètres de profondeur la pression
et mille fois supérieure par rapport à
la surface ça veut dire qu'il faut un
bon sous-marin bien solide qui résiste
bien à la pression
sinon on se retrouve face à un risque de
mort important je propose d'envoyer
Valentine au fond de la fosse des
Mariannes pour la science ça manque de
subtilité comme projet d'assassinat
attendez je crois que ma sœur Fiona il
est déjà
elle a l'air de s'y plaire la fausse des
Mariannes est dans le Pacifique
Nord-Ouest entre les Philippines la
Papouasie Nouvelle-Guinée et le Japon
elle se trouve sur une zone où la plaque
tectonique Pacifique passe sous celle
des Philippines et comme l'a dit l'autre
il y a quelques instants c'est l'endroit
le plus profond de l'océan connu à ce
jour environ 11000 mètres de profondeur
je suis pas sûr que vous vous rendiez
bien compte de ce que ça représente
11000 mètres de profondeur vous voyez
l'Everest c'est un genre de gros caillou
pointu bah admettons que vous le souliez
qu'un petit transpalette tout ce qu'il y
a de plus de transpalette et que vous le
retourniez dans l'océan et ben on
verrait quand même rien dépasser de
l'eau parce que l'Everest et 8848 m et
que le transpalette c'est 1m20 cette
fausse on l'a découverte en 1875 c'était
pendant la toute première campagne
océanique menée par la Royal Navy
l'objectif était de cartographier les
fonds marins mais le papier sous l'eau
ça tient pas bien la première fois que
des personnes sont allées au fond de la
fosse des Mariannes c'était en 1960 soit
9 ans avant le premier homme sur la Lune
Jacques Piccard et down rolls sont
descendus à 10916 mètres de profondeur
pour ça ils étaient à bord du bathyscaf
Trieste sur ce je vais aller lécher des
cailloux ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai bien
conscience que certains d'entre vous ne
savent pas ce qu'est un bathyscaf
heureusement je suis là pour te laisser
leur expliquer un bâtisse CAF est un
sous-marin d'exploration des grandes
profondeurs l'appareil a été inventé par
Auguste Picard le père de Jacques Picard
le mot Baptiste CAF est composé de deux
mots grecs battus qui signifie profond
et SCAF qui signifie barque c'est
exactement ça le profond barque on peut
ajouter aussi que sur un bâtisse CAF il
y a des caméras des instruments
scientifiques des bras robotiques tout
ce qu'il faut pour faire l'exploration
et de la Recherche et Auguste Picard a
aussi inventé le ballon à hydrogène pour
aller explorer la stratosphère oh le con
il étudie les fonds marins dans le ciel
anecdote Hergé ce serait inspiré de lui
pour créer le professeur Tournesol dans
les aventures de Tintin c'est cocasse du
coup la fosse des Mariannes c'est un
sujet intéressant parce que pendant des
années on pensait qu'on y trouverait
rien du tout il paraît même qu'on
voulait y mettre les déchets nucléaires
hop ni vu ni connu sauf qu'en fait bah
il y a de la vie tout au fond de la mer
donc finalement on enfouit les déchets
nucléaires sous terre parce que sous
terre il y a juste des vers de terre des
pommes de terre et des pommes de terre
donc on s'en fout mais c'est vrai qu'à
11000 mètres de profondeur on a du mal à
imaginer qu'il puisse y avoir un début
de petite crevettes je vous l'ai dit la
pression et mes gars importantes et à
200 mètres de profondeur la lumière
passe même plus à titre personnel j'ai
envie d'appeler ça le mur de plonges des
Mariannes
c'est une bague de scientifique
absence de vie
parce que sinon Louis Braille il serait
déjà mort
en 1960 alors qu'un petit club de
crevettes se baladait au fond de la
fausse des Mariannes sans doute dans
l'objectif d'aller à la mer entre
copines un objet non d'identifier avec
son bord de spécimens d'une espèce
inconnue a fait éruption sur son
territoire oh mon dieu Yvette mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc qui
mange qui descend du plafond d'eau j'en
sais rien Bernadette je n'avais jamais
vu ça avant mais quelle horreur il y a
des choses vivantes à l'intérieur on
dirait un bocal à une main rouge mais il
y aurait de la vie dans le plafond d'eau
attends Yvette demandons à Nicolas le
poisson plat il est expert en vie
inconnu Nicolas le poisson plat
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette chose qui
vient de débarquer du plafond d'eau
il semblerait qu'il s'agisse d'une
nouvelle espèce
appelons-la humain
Nicolas le poisson plat comment fais-tu
pour fumer ta pipe sous l'eau elle
devrait s'éteindre tu as raison
Bernadette je fume du tabac mouillé
depuis des années mais il n'existe pas
encore de cigarette électroniques qui
fonctionnent sous l'eau pendant leur
expédition au fond de la fosse des
mariages Jacques Picard et John walls
ont croisé des crevettes et une espèce
de poisson plat inconnu oh Nicolas le
poisson plage doit avouer que je t'ai
toujours aimé tu es si intelligent et
j'aime les poissons intelligents oh
Bernadette j'aime les petites crevettes
dans ton genre épouse-moi
c'était pas censé partir toi si mais
j'ai une attirance profonde pour les
gens mais les ans il y a donc de la vie
au fond de la fosse des mariages des
Mariannes des mariams mets de la vie
bien différente de ce qu'on a l'habitude
de voir sur la surface de l'eau parce
que sans lumière est donc sans végétaux
les habitants des fonds marins se
nourrissent de quoi et bah
principalement de ce qu'on appelle la
neige abyssale oh là là mais il faut
vraiment réparer ce plafond d'eau voilà
qu'il neige à VISSAL ne vous inquiétez
pas Madame Yvette je vais vous réparer
ça mais vous n'êtes pas le bon requin
outil
en gros la neige abyssale ce sont tous
les restes organiques qui viennent de la
surface d'autres espèces vont plutôt
filtrer le sable pour trouver des restes
et d'autres mangent les carcasses
d'animaux morts quand ils en trouvent
pas touché à ma jumelle morte non mais
genre des baleines oui bah c'est bien ce
que je dis et du coup c'est charognard
ne se déplace pas très vite pour éviter
de cramer toute leur réserves
énergétiques parce que oui une carcasse
de baleine ça tombe pas tous les jours
du ciel d'eau parmi les espèces
incroyables qu'on retrouve dans la fosse
des Mariannes il y a par exemple
l'incroyable poisson revenant et même
quand vous le remontez à la surface il
explose le poisson revenant ou bar et
l’œil du Pacifique ou macropina
microstoma est un poisson mesurant 15 cm
de long il fait partie de la famille des
hôpitaux proctite à les hôpitaux machins
se sont des poissons qui ont une tête
transparente littéralement on voit leur
globe oculaire à travers c'est
dégueulasse et donc oui ils font bien 15
cm autre espèce des abysses un peu moins
dégueulasse mais plutôt effrayante la
baudroie abyssale avec sa lanterne là et
plein de dents dans sa bouche et bien
sachez que cette espèce a une méthode de
reproduction des plus romantique les
femelles mesurent environ 20 cm alors
que le mal ne dépasse pas les 3 cm loser
le petit mâle va se fixer sur la femelle
puis fusionner avec elle pour une vie
pleine d'amour de passion et de fusion
on appelle ça le parasitisme sexuel oh
arrête de me parasiter Nicolas mais moi
je veux faire l'amour
autre espèce bien dégueulasse et
extrêmement connue le blobfish ce
poisson a une apparence flasque des eaux
tout mou aucune musculature une chair de
faible densité il a pas dedans et il se
nourrit de neige sous-marine les
scientifiques se demandent comment il
fait pour supporter la pression de
l'environnement dans lequel il vit autre
espèce plutôt effrayante le requin lutin
qui n'a rien à voir avec un lutin je
sais pas pourquoi ils l'ont appelé comme
ça mais c'est complètement con le requin
lutin ou mitsoukorina
ostoni un long museau plat doté de
capteurs électriques pour mieux détecter
ses proies il a la capacité de propulser
sa mâchoire vers l'avant c'est
dégueulasse il peut faire jusqu'à 6
mètres de long et très lent parce qu'il
y a deux petites nageoires il a jamais
connu de mutation génétique au fil du
temps on appelle ça une espèce panique
et pour finir une espèce unique en son
genre qu'on a observé qu'une seule fois
10898 mètres de profondeur le James
cameronus
en 2012 le réalisateur américain réalise
non pas Titanic 2 mais un rêve atteindre
le fond de la fosse des Mariannes alors
évidemment ce n'était pas juste un
caprice de personnes riches de Real qui
travaille dans le silence c'était dans
le cadre d'une expédition scientifique
l'expédition a été l'occasion de
collecter des spécimens marins destinés
à être étudié par des biologistes des
exobiologistes des géologues et des géo
physiciens et il faut continuer à
étudier nos fonds marins parce qu'on les
connaît pas bien et comme on les connaît
pas bien on risque de faire n'importe
quoi vous saviez qu'on a retrouvé du
plastique à 11000 mètres de profondeur
merci Valentine pour son expertise du
jour nous ne manquerons pas de la revoir
dans une prochaine vidéo si cet épisode
pas du tout spatial vous a plu ne
manquez pas de nous le faire savoir et
on pourra sans doute faire d'autres
épisodes pas du tout spatiaux qui vous
plaisent et que vous ne manquerez pas de
nous le faire savoir de la saison 4